[Musique]
allo icat cette faute espère voir ce
soit chez toi tu me remplacer pas qu'on
dise je m'en de la côte rapt un jeu
s'emballe pour une heure de taf mais
j'aime pas ça parce que je suis pas
dealer
puis c'est ça que j'étais pourquoi il ya
un pas que la 4g programme par livraison
minimum bakassi birdies à ses huit
français et trois de cinq ans elle est
trop bonne sakho et première fois qu'on
s'était contractée avec tes potes latin
je suis pas fait pour continuer à vendre
leur attaquant donc ça je suis pas
dealer moi je croise un pote et un
disque dur nas est juste à côté le mans
ciblant une coque fois que le petit tu
verras tu es tenir caso de paname j'ai
déjà la ferme est bon 3 g mairie
[Musique]
peterson coster plus que 6 me pourquoi
malikite avec simone c'est pourri comme
ce dossier vraiment vraiment
[ __ ]
[Musique]